hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
one of the things that's seemingly
getting harder these days is to find
your very first internship or a job as a
software engineer it's even more
competitive than ever before to get into
a computer science or software
engineering program to begin with and
securing that first job feels like you
have to like jump across this 3 000 foot
cliff to get to the other side which is
employment so when it comes to actually
finding a job it's a big feat and a
pretty big deal but it's hard to know
what to do or even where to start in the
first place where are you supposed to
look even to find jobs do you look on
linkedin or other job boards are you
supposed to directly apply to jobs on
their careers page and while we're at it
what's your resume even supposed to look
like i actually made a video about this
you can check it out right there does
writing a cover letter help i also made
a video about that one there are a lot
of things to consider so i recently
spoke to my friend sarah at levels.fyi
and asked her questions like this she's
been a recruiter at multiple fang
companies including amazon facebook and
google and has helped people find jobs
all over the tech industry the real
truth is that while the job search
experience varies from person to person
in the tech industry there is at least
some sort of process that everyone seems
to follow and so there's at least a few
things that you can do to make your life
easier and set yourself up for success
and i think one thing to remember is
that recruiters are really trying to
find someone and find the right person
for the job that's probably easy to
forget after you apply to your 200th job
they want to do as good of a job as they
can and they might also be needing to
negotiate with a hiring manager who has
their own priorities and goals so all
those factors time budgets who else is
involved in the process influences where
recruiters look for candidates so
knowing all this where is the best place
to put yourself as a candidate sarah
breaks it down into three big chunks job
sites referrals and events and before we
continue i wanted to say a quick thank
you to felix gray for sponsoring today's
video yes a lot of y'all ask about what
glasses i wear and these are felix greys
and i love them so five years ago felix
gray realized that we're not meant to be
looking at computer screens all day and
so they designed glasses to make daily
screen time more comfortable so the
lenses in these glasses actually filter
15 times more blue light which is a
thing that makes screen time really like
tough on the eyes and makes sleep very
disruptive so the ones that i'm wearing
are the robling in amber toffee and the
low nose bridge fit style because your
girl's asian and she has a flat face
they offer classic styles that are made
from acetate and are hand finished for a
durable lightweight and very comfortable
pair of glasses oh and these blue light
lenses are also available in
non-prescription or prescription as well
these have prescription in them because
my optometrist was like if you don't
wear these your eyes are just gonna get
worse which actually though ever since i
started wearing these my eyes have not
gotten worse which is great so if you
can feel the screen time in your
eyeballs or you just really want to try
blue light glasses then try felix gray
with their 30 day money back guarantee
there's literally nothing to lose but
eye strain thank you again felix gray
for sponsoring make sure to check them
out in the description box down below
and let's get back to the video
so every company has like a jobs page
where they post new listings for
openings of their company but it can be
impossible to keep up with like all
those individual companies and
refreshing pages like facebook.com
careers like 20 times a day so there's
an entire ecosystem of job sites that
place all these job listings in one
place like linkedin indeed monster and
angel list so when you think of job
sites of course linkedin is probably the
first to come to mind but one thing that
i learned is that linkedin is actually
really saturated with candidates
i feel like everyone will say like
linkedin would be like the first place
that they go to but linkedin is really
saturated and it's expensive for company
to post jobs on there so usually when
they post a dropped on linkedin is
because these are typically harder to
fill roles so companies are looking for
something very specific with anything
that they have on linkedin so the best
place to look actually frankly is where
others aren't so she says to kind of
branch out and try all the different job
sites that you can i think indeed is
really underrated she also recommends
angellist which fun fact is where i
found my job at patreon in general job
sites like linkedin and indeed are
totally fine to apply to but it's
actually recommended to find what's
called a job id on the listing you can
use that id to find the job on the
actual careers page of that company and
apply to that directly most likely i'll
ask the candidate again can you fill out
your application using this link
so um just to make things a little bit
easier on the company and the recruiter
if you see it on linkedin apply there
but go to the korea site and then just
do like the actual job application
anyways this is mostly because the
actual job listing on the company
website will have the required questions
that you need to fill out to apply to
the company versus aggregator sites and
job sites won't have stuff like that it
just makes the recruiters lives easier
if you give them all the information
they need on the first try sarah also
says that because there's so many steps
to the recruitment process if like a
recruiter quits or like they get
reassigned to a different team or role
or something then your application can
definitely fall through the cracks and
that does actually happen more than you
think so if you find a role that like
really resonates with you then go out
and find the actual hiring manager for
that job and reach out personally that
way even if the recruiter gets
reassigned you've contacted the main
person responsible for hiring for this
role what i like to do is i just go on
linkedin that say my dream company to
work for a sigma so i'll go on linkedin
and then i'll go through figma so i
would go into like the people tab and
then in like the box where it says like
search employees by title keyword or
school i usually just put down manager
and then it pull up like the right
manager for you to look through oh and
approach it from sarah you can go on
linkedin and look up keywords like we're
hiring or join our team that way you can
find people who are looking for
candidates in a slightly creative way
all right so first up what's a referral
it's when a friend colleague or
acquaintance of some sort refers or
recommends you to a job at their company
and usually when they refer you they
have to fill out a form that form
basically contains their connection to
you and their endorsement of you they'll
talk about how they know you and explain
why they think you're good at what you
do and also tell the company why you're
right for the role most of the time all
these referrals get to kind of like skip
the line as far as applications go
because a lot of them have a goal to
respond to these referrals in a timely
manner this doesn't mean that you'll
automatically get an interview or
whatever because it still has to get
reviewed by the hiring manager so yeah
referrals are just like more legitimate
connections and because of the process
they go through it's not even really
like nepotism that fuels it this is just
another way for recruiters to find
someone who might be right for the job
by any means at their disposal a
referral carry a lot of weight so if you
have someone who maybe work at google
and that's where you want to be
ask for a referral but also
make sure that you ask the right person
to like if you've worked with that
person in the past or like know that
person really well there were a handful
of times where people got in trouble for
referral fraud because they just submit
someone because they want that like
payout so a lot of employees like became
more aware of that so they tend to be a
little bit more careful in terms of like
who they refer so yeah referrals are
basically like asking someone to stick
out their neck for you so i wouldn't
recommend going to like random people or
people you only kind of know for a
referral especially if they just like
don't know you and they've never seen
your work so this is just another plus
one to the advice that i always say of
building strong and real connections
with people instead of just like adding
500 connections on linkedin
so events might actually sound kind of
weird on paper like they might be really
networking heavy or they're not actually
productive but they're really worth the
time and that's because recruiters and
hiring managers put a lot of effort into
putting on these events remember again
like they want to hire people like
that's their goal so they create these
events for people to go to it's like a
legitimate gathering so if you're
invited to one or you hear about one
then definitely go to them it takes a
lot of work to put an event together and
from a recruiter perspective like i know
that my upper management will ask me in
terms of like roi and metrics i can't
just put together an event and there
isn't a way for me to measure my roi
unless if i send candidates
that take home assignment and then from
there present you know like oh we put
out this event and it cost us this much
and on top of that we ended up getting
x amount of candidates and then here's
our conversion rate so that would be
like the best way for you to get notice
so really it all boils down to being
ready to present yourself trying your
best in whatever creative way possible
to put yourself in front of the people
who are hiring oh and if i might add
like one more piece of advice for this
journey don't be too concerned if like
things don't take off immediately a lot
of this stuff like applying to jobs
interviewing finding the right role for
you takes time anyone will tell you that
like good talent gets found one way or
another so if you're in think of it
right now applying for jobs trust me it
will work out ps what about those like
recruiting agencies that people talk
about are they useful should i talk to
them are they good at getting jobs if
you're interested in finding out the
answer to that question then i've
created it as bonus content for my
members on youtube you can get access by
becoming a member for as low as 99 cents
a month by clicking the join button down
below thank you again sarah from
levels.fyi for answering all of my
questions about the recruiting process
i'll leave her link and any other things
that i mentioned in the video today in
the description box down below thank you
so much to my youtube members for
supporting me and my work and these
videos don't forget to subscribe and
i'll see you all next time bye